we've cleared completely the area
where the bench is about another about a
mile Up From the Bench but around where
the phone was initially found so we've
done very thorough searches all the way
down to the Weir the police divers have
dived it three times extremely
thoroughly and they are highly competent
and we are and that area is completely
negative there is no sign of Nicola in
that particular area but we are here
this afternoon we're just going to do
one little area up the top what just
needs to be another bit of a search to
do and then at the end of the day we
will will be here our kit will stay here
but we'll go we're all tired I had three
hours sleep last night